so it's great to be here at PI data
I wish Wes could be here he's always
great to interact with like I said I'm
one and I'm gonna be talking about
project Jupiter in particular the
notebook and a bit about myself here so
first of all I'm gonna be giving the
entire talk using the Jupiter notebook
just to see sort of where we're at with
everyone in the room how many people
here have used the Jupiter notebook
before okay fantastic
so because of that I won't spent quite
as much time as I normally would giving
an introduction and I'll try to talk
about some more so some of the more
interesting and advanced part of the
project but I also think it's useful to
give a little bit of background about
how the Jupiter knows folks came to be
so you can see here my quote day job it
is as a physics and data science
professor at Cal Poly Cal Poly's a
California state school on the Central
Coast of California where it is most
certainly not raining today and hasn't
probably for two years I was trained as
a physicist at the University of
Colorado computational and theoretical
atomic physics and at least in my own
journey how I got involved in open
source was I found that the places where
I was struggling most in my physics
research was not the physics but was
really the computational tools that I
was using and in particular using us and
starting to use with students and that
was a very painful thing and that got me
to start to think about building tools I
will talk in in a few minutes about why
Jupiter and ipython were there two
things why did why do we talk more about
Jupiter now than we talk about ipython
and here's a short sort of outline and
the thing I want to start with is the
idea of a computational narrative and
this really underpins and is
Foundation for a lot of the way that we
think about interactive computing I
apologize the visibility of the screen
is not fantastic let's see I know that's
better but it also gets worse because so
little can be seen on the screen let's
it how bad is this in back it's bad so
so I will say there's a lot of chairs up
closer could you please move closer if I
do this well we'll see a lot of it
starts to look a horrible one there's
more content on the page but we'll do
this for a little while I can also do
some of this to get a little more space
on the screen so computational
narratives the first observation is that
computers are good at consuming
producing and processing data this is
really what we as humans build computers
for humans on the other hand are good at
consuming producing and processing
narratives or stories and if you doubt
this just look at the excitement about
Star Wars this coming out right a lot of
us grew up seeing the Star Wars movies
and they're really compelling for for
many people and there's a lot of
excitement around stories you can also
see the remnant of the fact that a
significant fraction of the entire
Internet
is occupied in serving stories in the
form of Netflix people people are
compelled by stories and because of this
for data to be useful to us as humans we
need tools for telling stories that
involve code and data and some of you in
the room may have seen this example
before that sort of illustrates this
idea the distinction between code and
data and and the embedding of that into
a story so you've probably seen a lot of
this stuff are already I'm gonna load a
matplotlib I'm actually not going to use
that read in a data frame can look at
the data frame you can see
there's some data here about city police
force size and then some percentages
that are broken down by by race and
we've got 76 records we can do some
summary statistics some transformations
here's a reduced data set and then you
see born to make a plot and at this
point I think it's fairly safe to say
that none of you would be willing to
risk your life based on the data that
you've seen even though there's a nice
pretty plot and yet the narrative around
this data is one in which many people
were willing to risk their lives and the
underlying story here is comes from
Ferguson Missouri from the end of last
year this is a data set that was written
about in 538 entitled most police don't
live in the cities they serve and just
to read a quote from from the article in
Ferguson Missouri where protests
continue following the shooting of a
teenager by a police officer this month
more than two-thirds of the civilian
population is black only 11% of the
police force is the racial disparity is
troubling enough on its own but it's
also suggestive another type of
misrepresentation given the Ferguson's
racial gap it's likely that many of its
police officers live outside the city
limits and so back to the box plot up
here what I'm showing you is a
percentage of police officers that live
in the cities they serve I think that's
right let's see yeah non white officers
are more likely to live in the cities
they serve white officers tend to live
elsewhere and obviously there's many
different ways that you could approach
the events in Ferguson Missouri from a
data perspective this is just one of
them but again the point that I want to
make is that without the story without
the narrative the data really doesn't
mean too much to us we're not really
willing to make decisions based on that
or or have it affect our lives in a
meaningful way and so this idea of a
computational narrative
really foundational when we think about
interactive computing and to put it
bluntly if all you have is code and data
and there's no narrative it just doesn't
mean what no one is going to be able to
do much with that from a practical
perspective so so ipython and Jupiter
our main goals are centered around
interactive computing first of all we
since the beginning have often it
offered an environment for doing
computations that are interactive that
involve some sort of human steering of
the computation in the middle while the
computation is live and then the this
idea of a computational narrative around
that interactive computation ipython was
started in 2001 by Fernando Perez
if Fernando and I were classmates in
graduate school at the University of
Colorado between 2001 and 2004 Fernando
and I had conversations where he was
really excited about this new Python
thing and thought it was gonna really
change how everyone did computing and I
think it's interesting from a historical
perspective that even all the way back
then in 2001 the the excitement that
Fernando had about Python was completely
present it was fully realized it's not
at the time I had no sense that this was
a really risky crazy thing it was like
of course it has to be Python it's
amazing it's fantastic at the time he
and I were doing a lot of our PhD work
using C++ mathematic Perl other tools
like that and he started ipython because
of his pain trying to get work done and
I joined ipython and started to work
with Fernando in 2004 and between 2004
and 2011 we continued to do a lot of
work on the traditional terminal based
ipython and in fact we made multiple
attempts during those years
build an interactive web-based notebook
and all those attempts got thrown away
so maybe from your perspective the
notebook sort of spontaneously came into
existence in 2011 it was a very slow
painful process for us to understand the
abstractions how do you build something
like this and also a lot of the tools
around web technologies were extremely
primitive at the time and a lot of the
things that we do just weren't possible
at the time we probably could have done
it but it would have been really really
painful
and honestly beyond our capabilities at
the time so the notebook came out in
2011 shortly thereafter we started to
really understand that the architecture
behind the notebook and that's really
two things one is the document format
itself so when you look at the file
system where you're running the Jupiter
or ipython notebook what you see is a
bunch of files with a dot I py and B
extension the notebook files are JSON
data that store both the code for a
computation the narrative text around
the code and then all results related to
that code including visualizations and
so that's one piece of the architecture
another piece is the network protocol
that we use for the web browser to
communicate with the backend process
which we call the kernel that runs code
in a particular language and the
realization was for the most part those
two abstractions were completely
independent of Python we had a few small
places where we were sort of have had
Python isms present over the subsequent
years we removed all those and built an
architecture that is really meant to be
language independent and so for example
so if I go to tip and be well I thought
yeah sorry I probably don't have a
network connection no okay it could be
fun firewall things let's see temp be
okay sorry I will refrain from saying
anything at this point about people
breaking the Internet if you were to go
to temp and be you can see that there's
a drop-down menu where you can select
between a number of different languages
ranging from Python to Python 3 julia r
skaila and spark back here the the
representation that is right here I only
have the bash Python 3 and our kernels
installed so as we built out the
language independent aspects of the
project it really became problematic
trying to explain to people that they
should run their julia code in an
environment called ipython or that they
should run their our code in an
environment called ipython so last
summer we started a new project it's
really the same group of people that
have been building ipython all along
that we're calling Jupiter and Jupiter
is the new home for all of the language
independent pieces of this architecture
you may be wondering well what about a
Python has it gone away
no ipython continues to exist it is the
Python specific parts of the
architecture so if we go here and go
over to this page this is a list of the
current kernels that we know of that
have been written for Jupiter and what
you see here hi Julia is the the kernel
for Jupiter that runs code in Julia I
Haskell for Haskell I have sharp for F
sharp a ruby and so on so at this point
I Python is one among many peers as a
kernel that can run code in a particular
language on the Jupiter architecture I
think that's all I want to cover in that
notebook
I'm actually for now gonna skip my
standard don't look to her it sounds
like most of the audience uses the
notebook and would probably fall asleep
if I cover that content
I do want to mention briefly this Bash
notebook so Bash is one of the kernels
that exists for Jupiter and I think for
me this this emphasizes the narrative
aspect of this now you might say well
why do I need a bash Colonel when I can
go over here and just say new terminal
and I can run arbitrary code here in
bash I can start VI do anything I want
right from from the web browser why do I
need a notebook and it really gets back
to this idea of a narrative and being
able to construct a narrative that has
the code that's reproducible there are a
lot of existing command line tools that
different groups use that their workflow
is basically a bunch of bash commands
linked together with the notebook you
can combine those bash commands into a
narrative that's reproducible and so I
mean this is not a particularly
interesting narrative it's just showing
you that here the bash kernel works as
the other kernels so for example you can
define a variable and bash and in the
next cell
access that variable the colonel is
stateful just like the other kernels
tab-completion works so we can say right
I can tab complete and say oh maybe I
want easy install something you can even
define bash functions here's a display
function that taps into the display
architecture of the notebook and when I
cat an image and pipe it to that
function I see the image here in the
notebook in case you haven't seen it
the notebook generalizes the idea of
output beyond just textual output to
include other mime types so image mime
types SVG HTML javascript even law tech
yes yes so the function is a little bit
of magic but basically what this does is
the Bosch Colonel watches the file
system for files that are put in a
particular place and when they are it
grabs the data and sends it back to the
to the notebook using our display
message protocols
most of the other kernels handle display
in a slightly more sophisticated way the
bash kernel is somewhat simplistic but
it's also really nice because you end up
being able to do things like like this
that from a conceptual perspective make
a lot of sense the notebook ecosystem so
around the notebook there are a lot of
other tools I'm mostly here going to
talk about tools that we ourselves as a
project to build and maintain the first
is and be convert and be convert is a
command-line tool for converting
notebook files to different static
formats this includes static HTML
markdown restructure text lot tech and
PDF and then reveal j/s slideshows next
is NB viewer and B viewer is basically
NB convert as a website so let's see if
I have enough in hey I have enough
internet so this is the NB viewer
website and you can paste the URL or the
github information for any notebook
that's public and we will render that as
static HTML and so here's just an
example this is a notebook that looks at
the xkcd style plotting in matplotlib
and the important thing here is that the
the code it still looks like a notebook
visually but the code is not that can't
be edited and it also cannot be run in
this context and initially Matthias one
of our core devs
developed and B view or over a weekend
and and we said well let's try putting
it up and it's turned out to be
extremely popular as a way of sharing
technical content
if you think about it a few years ago if
you had a document that had code and
data and mathematical equations and you
wanted to share it with people and tweet
about it where would you post that I
mean you could try to post this on a
blog which was difficult and and part of
what we're also finding is that the
other venue people would post these
things were like formal academic
publications the difficulty with that is
that the timescales for it are really
long by the time it actually gets
published you're probably long working
on something else and also the
accessibility question many if not most
academic journals are not freely
available to the public you have to be
at a relatively wealthy US university
that has subscription to those journals
otherwise people can't look at it and so
n be viewer has been very useful for
sharing a notebook based content as I
mentioned in my talk yesterday as a
spring of this year
github also renders notebooks in place
on github the the big difference between
the notebook rendering on github versus
NB viewer and actually let me go back to
and be view or show you an example here
so this is a notebook that has bouquet
visualizations and we can just pick
linked brushing so notice it says Bocage
is successfully loaded and then as a
when I go down here I have live
interactive plotting on and B viewer and
as I mentioned the notebook documents
contain all of the output in all the
different formats and this is how a
library like bouquet works it embeds
JavaScript and HTML in the output area
and when that notebook is gets moved
around that runs and you can see the
visualization the problem with that
from a security perspective is that I
could write a notebook that contained
arbitrary JavaScript and you are then
going to open open that on a computer
that likely has some something valuable
for example like all of your files
you can imagine the difficulty if github
allowed arbitrary JavaScript from
notebooks to run on github for example
someone could write a notebook that
simply deletes all of your github
repositories that would be a very
unpopular feature and so github cleans
most of the HTML and all of the
JavaScript when the notebooks are
rendered on their platform
I don't it's really unfortunate but I
don't see that changing anytime soon I
think it's a very good reason on in the
viewer we have no authentication
contexts whatsoever and so it's a fairly
safe platform for us to allow arbitrary
JavaScript so that's an important
difference all right this is really an
advertisement for a talk by Jeremy
Freeman Jeremy are you here in the room
he's probably getting ready for his talk
a project called binder and I'm not
gonna spend a lot of time because you
should just go to his talk here pie data
and hear about it so we have the ability
to share notebooks on github render them
on github or in B viewer but what you
would really like is for users on the
Internet to be able to actually play
with your code and that's exactly what
binder offers with binder you basically
get a little badge in your github
repository and then anyone in the world
can run run that code so go to Jeremy
Freeman's talk I don't know exactly what
it is I think it is this afternoon but
you can look at that up temp NB is
another it's a website that's broken
here at Bank of America it is another
website that you can visit to get a sort
of a transient notebook server in a
docker container we find that temp NB is
really nice for quick demos so you're
someplace you don't have your laptop and
someone says well what about that
differential equation or that function
or can we plot this and you say oh I
have 10 pen B temp in B org you've got
notebooks in Python to Python 3 or Julia
and I think skaila and spark as well
it's all right there
now temp and B is not designed for
persistent work The Notebook after you
leave your temp and B docker container a
short while later we blast it away and
all of the work you've done is going to
vanish so don't use it for important
work you will be disappointed
Jupiter hub on the other hand is a
multi-user server that's designed to run
in a persistent manner for organizations
so for example at Cal Poly where I teach
our College has a Jupiter hub deployment
that everyone in the college all
students all faculty can use that's
connected on the back end to our cluster
integrated with our Active Directory
authentication here's just a screenshot
of a demo Jupiter hub instance that we
have there's two aspects of Jupiter hub
that are plugable the first is the
authentication by default it uses pan
based authentication on unix systems but
it we also have support for OAuth in
particular Google and github
ooofff and so this particular server is
using github ooofff and I can simply add
a new account by asking for someone's
user username on github very nice
and I want to emphasize that all the
work you do on a Jupiter hub instance is
persistent so you know your notebooks
will be there two weeks when you come
back
so I think one of the most fun aspects
of working on this project is seeing
what different people are doing with the
notebook and so I want to spend some
time just walking you through some
really interesting applications of it
first in the area of publishing Matthew
Russell has written a very nice uh Riley
book called mining the social web that
includes Jupiter notebooks for all of
the examples another great example is of
a more traditional academic book is this
book python for signal processing and by
jose and pico it's a springer title and
it's an actual sort of traditional
hardback academic book and he wrote the
book originally as a series of blog
posts that were ipython notebooks and
then took those notebooks to springer
and began to work with them on the book
for technical blogging I think one of
the best example examples of this is the
pythonic perambulations by Jake van der
plas at the University of Washington if
you have not read his blog I highly
encourage it he is an excellent author
at really in our words building
computational narratives right building
a story around code and data and so when
Jake publishes a blog post like this you
can see there's equations here there's
code there's visualizations all of this
started out as an eye - notebook which
Jake then uses and be convert to convert
it to static HTML and I think that the
blog engine he uses Pelican that has
integration with this as well Jake has
also written some more formal works
he wrote this blog post for Scientific
American on four-dimensional
distributions of asteroids and again it
started out as a notebook another really
exciting thing is what Oh Riley media is
doing they're embracing the notebook
at a fairly deep level the first is that
they have this new learning site and
here's an example actually this is
another example from Jake van der plas
introduction to s VMs and let's actually
see beta yes so here I can show you the
live website so here's so some content
on the arathi website and the code has a
little Run button here and the second I
hit run it fires up a notebook server
behind the scenes now it doesn't use the
actual notebook user interface it only
uses the kernels and it actually is
running on top of temp and B and all the
code is live code I can go in and change
it modify it and it's an example where
someone is taking the fundamental
building blocks required for interactive
computing namely you need a process that
runs code and you need the ability to
communicate with that process through
some means but deploying it in the
context where there's no notebook
present right and along with this actual
website O'Reilly has this open source
project called feeb and the github link
is here that is basically the JavaScript
required to put those code cells onto
any webpage that you want so that that's
another example of that here is an
example from academic publications the I
should mention the notebook gallery is
on our wiki page in the ipython ipython
repo and we have a very very long list
of just interesting notebooks that we
think are notable and there is a section
on actual peer-reviewed research this is
one example so this is a a paper written
in Nature Genetics
here's a screenshot of the actual nature
website and then associated with that is
a
github repository hmm that's odd
sorry I think I will have to figure out
what's going on with that link but they
have a github repository that has all of
their analyses for the paper as Jupiter
notebooks and it's I think it's actually
let me see
part of what I think is really
interesting about this case is the the
amount of material that they have
provided here and I think one part about
reproducibility in data science and
scientific computing whether it's in an
academic setting or not is that
typically that the thing that shows up
at the end of the day as an article a
blog post is just the tip of the iceberg
the actual analysis that went into it is
massive and so I mean there's probably
what 20 different notebooks here and
let's just pick one of those 20
notebooks and look at it so again look
at the length of the scroll bar on the
right it's incredible now when I first
saw this I I think part of my my
response was wow that that's a little
bit like overkill maybe but when you
think about it how much worse is it that
someone would publish an article
requiring this much analysis and leave
that analysis out
there's no way anyone would ever be able
to reproduce that work and I think this
is a really important point to remember
about reproducibility
here's another short example actually
I'm going to skip that one want to jump
ahead
so here's some examples of the notebook
being used in journalism and the first
is from Jeremy singer vine and John
Templin at BuzzFeed news I know you
pretty much probably don't associate
BuzzFeed with serious data-driven
journalism but Jeremy and Don Teflon and
some other people there and their group
who are doing absolutely fantastic work
and in our minds really setting a gold
standard for what it means to do
reproducible data science so here is
their github organization they have a
repo entitled everything that is an
index every article they write that's
backed by data is given its own github
repository and that github repository
contains both the data for the article
and the code and analysis as Jupiter
notebooks right and so here's one one
example here's the the article
immigration authorities are far more
likely to GL you if you're Mexican sort
of has a traditional like BuzzFeed twist
on the title of the article but a rather
serious issue and here's a screenshot of
the github repository with the analysis
behind that and again part of what's so
notable about this is that they have
committed to do this for all of their
data-driven articles they're not sort of
after the fact making sort of decisions
about well should we open this one up or
not they've just said we're doing this
for everything the LA Times has recently
gotten into this game as well this is a
fairly recent article about the LAPD
missmiss reporting how serious crimes
are to try to make it appear that crime
is going down under their watch when it
actually that was not the case and the
analysis was quite significant and again
they posted their data and the analysis
on github
the last thing I want to talk about is
the usage of the Jupiter notebook in
commercial products and this is one
point that I think is quite important
Jupiter and ipython are completely
open-source projects we're licensed
under the three clause BSD license and
it's not just about it we are using of
an open-source license it's also the
fact that all the development on our
project is done out in the open that's
not to say we don't have private
conversations but we try very hard after
we have private conversations to post a
summary to github or to our mailing list
it's turned out to be quite challenging
to engage with large companies in a
particular how to find a level playing
field where all these different
companies many of whom compete directly
against each other can come together and
work on the project and we're we're
really pleased with how this is going
but we will be the first ones to
acknowledge that this is really a
growing period for us and these
companies figuring out how do we do this
together one of the early examples of
the notebook being used in a commercial
product is the quanto peon research
platform quanto peon is a boston-based
algorithmic trading platform I think
some of the quanto peon people are here
at PI data they're doing absolutely
fantastic work and their entire research
platform is based on the Jupiter
notebook this summer Microsoft released
to prod products that have the Jupiter
notebook as the user interface one is as
your ml which is their machine learning
platform on their cloud platform Azure
and the other is HD insight HD insight
provides SPARC clusters as a service and
the user interface for that is again the
Jupiter notebook
data iku offers a product called the
data science studio this is an on
premise
science environment and again the user
interface for this is again the Jupiter
notebook data robot is building a
machine learning platform that helps you
sift through different classifiers
and find one that works well for your
data and one of the interfaces that they
offer is the Jupiter notebook a fairly
recent addition to this space is the
Google Cloud data lab this is a there's
a couple different efforts at Google
involving the Jupiter notebook this is
one particular one and basically you can
see here import GCP bigquery as BQ so
the idea is that they want an
interactive platform for you to use
their different cloud-based services and
are often offering the notebook in that
y-hat rodeo is another interesting take
on this this is a completely separate
user interface than the Jupiter notebook
web application but underneath that
still reuses all of the architecture so
they're still using Jupiter kernels and
network protocols and some aspects of
the server as well we're really excited
to see where sort of the the
intersection of open-source tools and
the application of those in commercial
products and I think with that I will
wrap up and I think we have maybe have
time for a few questions
all right fire away
or not
I read in your recent grant proposal the
intent to make notebooks more like
regular software when it comes to
modularization testing cooperation
versioning can you talk about that a
little bit maybe yeah
there's much more than I can talk about
quickly if you go to the blog Jupiter
org new funding for Jupiter there's a
blog post that talks a lot more about
this we are currently in the process of
breaking our monolithic JavaScript
front-end code base into a lot of
loosely coupled NPM packages and then
reassembling those in a way that really
emphasizes extensibility and so we're
gonna have basically if you have an NPM
package we will make it very easy for
you to get that into our user interface
and integrate with all of our api's so
the bash kernel looks really cool I had
known about that that might be a big
blessing for system ins yeah but um is
there a next o and SH kernel yet what
kernel excellent SH you know the colonel
oh yes that and Anthony's scope that
says yeah exactly I don't know
I'm looking at having to integrate a new
IDE into an existing monolithic program
would I be better off waiting until you
finished a refactoring or shad start now
yes yes no the refactoring is happening
very quickly and within a few months
we'll be you you can start to build on
this stuff I have a future requests yes
so whenever you open the notebook you
hit the menu bar and you hit the other
bar can we have a global checkpoint
checkbox that does it in all notebooks
always no I want to check I know it can
edit the CSS files and JavaScript files
to inject yes to make it easier to make
it easier to turn back on and off
because I mean yeah thank you
good idea what some what did you
consider best practice for using ipython
notebooks with kondeh environments it's
because I know you can with each
environment and can include I find that
notebooks but it gets pretty hard to
keep track unless you organize
everything in different directories
about which environment you're using
yeah so the way that I think a lot of us
are starting to do that is to basically
just install kernels to the different
environments and then launch the
notebook server once and then be able to
pick in your list of kernels from the
different environments
so there's I would have to look it up
there's a few people that have started
to write tools to do that type of thing
I yeah so that we can talk afterwards or
I can yeah it does exist okay we should
think thank you
you